Well,
I think that the community and the
loving and the end,
the care that you can get from religion
are very good things,
of course.
And if only there were more purely
secular groups that provided not only
the good works but also the community.
I think that would be a good thing.
I'm a,
I've been talking with various people
about the need to,
uh,
provide that structure in secular
organizations and I think it's possible
and I think we should work at it because
you're absolutely right.
People sometimes when there's nobody
around to love you and take care of you.
It's great to have a group that you can
be welcomed into.
Well,
I suppose the simplest answer is it
would be good if there were a,
and there are already a churches without
dogmas and in fact,
uh,
more and more churches downplay dogma to
the point of evaporation and concentrate
on providing just the sort of a,
um,
a community of care,
mutual care and,
and I'm helping the world.
And so I think it's entirely possible
that churches will evolve into sort of
creedless organizations that do a lot of
good work.
And that would be wonderful.